SIMONE PETTIGREW: Probably the most substantial benefit
that we can gain from autonomous vehicles is accident reduction.
Around 93% of all accidents are just down to human error.
So we go through stop signs or red lights.
We don't see oncoming traffic, et cetera.
Autonomous vehicles are expected to eradicate almost all
of those accidents.
In Australia, we lose about 1,200 people a year who die on the roads.
If we can get rid of 93% of those accidents,
you're saving more than 1,000 lives per year.
The other consideration, of course, are people
who don't die, but end up in hospital.
Often, they're quite severe accidents, and they can be in rehab
for the rest of their lives.
We have, again, about 34,000 Australians end up
in hospital due to traffic accidents each year.
If we can get rid of 93% of those hospital visits,
that would be freeing up entire hospital wings and rehabilitation centers.
The ongoing benefits to society will be huge,
as well as for those individuals who won't be
harmed who would have been otherwise.
The cost savings are expected to be around $16 billion a year
just in crash prevention alone.
If we think about the fact that we have an aging population,
and it's aging rapidly.
We've got that huge baby boomer segment that's
just entered the retirement years.
Autonomous vehicles are understood to be a huge boon for this group.
They'll actually be able to stay a lot more mobile for a lot longer
once they can use vehicles that don't rely on their faculties
to be able to drive.
So lots of potential there to do lots of wonderful things
to help people who are really quite disadvantaged, particularly,
say, blind people, who have never had the opportunity to go anywhere
on their own in a vehicle, would be able to, with voice activation,
just be able to program a vehicle to take them wherever they wanted to go.
SCOTT HOLLIER: I'm Dr Scott Hollier.
I'm a digital access specialist.
I've worked in the corporate government and not-for-profit sectors
for about 15 years, and a big part of my focus
is to ensure that people with disabilities
get access to computers and internet-related technologies.
Autonomous vehicles offer a huge potential for people with disabilities.
As a legally blind person, I'm very much looking forward to the day
when I'll be able to jump into an autonomous vehicle
and it can take me to where I want to go.
It's not only beneficial in terms of getting me somewhere,
but it also helps to address issues that I face now, such as my current need
to live near public transport.
It's exciting to that if I did have a driverless car an autonomous vehicle
that I could potentially live anywhere because I'm no longer restricted
by that need to be close to shops or close to public transport.
So the benefits would really open up for someone such as myself.
I think one of the benefits of autonomous vehicles
is that it does provide a lot of independence.
Again, to use myself as an example, to have the ability
to just pop to the shops, or be able to go watch my son play soccer,
or my daughter play golf, without the need
to have significant coordination of going places, given that I can't drive,
it would be great to be able to just jump in the car
and go places, something which I can't do at the moment.
So I think it does give you a lot of flexibility, a lot of independence.
The timing becomes a lot easier.
For people, for example, who use a wheelchair
and rely a lot on wheelchair taxis, autonomous vehicles
mean they'd be able to better manage the time.
They don't have to rely on how quickly or how far away a taxi is,
and be able to just go in something and do what you want to do.
So it would significantly help in relation to independence.
SIMONE PETTIGREW: Like every other innovation,
there are going to be downsides.
And we're going to need to work through those to make sure
that they're not disadvantaging people.
So as we said, one of them is that perhaps people
will end up using cars more rather than less,
because they've become more dependent on them, because they're so convenient.
Other risks include things like carjacking,
where you could worry about people who are very technology-savvy infiltrating
a system and commanding vehicles to all turn 90 degrees right now and run
into brick walls or people.
Those kinds of scenarios are very unlikely.
We have lots of agencies in Australia and internationally
that are working very hard on making sure that those kinds of issues
don't occur, and perhaps think back to our airplane
example, in that those systems also have to be hijack-proof.
So we are accustomed to coming up with systems to get around that,
but it does take a lot of effort and some very big brains
out there to be working on that constantly,
and to be preempting any kind of problems that may occur.
PAUL NICHOLLS: One of the great things about autonomous vehicle trials
is it also helps us to better understand the privacy
concerns of the people that use it.
With an autonomous vehicle trial, there are
lots of sensors collecting lots of information about the individuals.
There are cameras on board the actual system.
There are cameras on the external of the system.
We actually are very careful to make sure
that people are aware that their data is being collected.
SIMONE PETTIGREW: We've been surveying Australians for the last year or so.
We've surveyed around 1,600 Australian drivers aged 16-plus,
and we've said to them, what do you know about autonomous vehicles?
How do you feel about them?
What do you think the biggest positives are?
What do you think the biggest negatives are?
Fortunately, the overall attitude seems to be reasonably neutral.
So on a five-point scale, most people were kind of around three saying,
I think I'm interested, but I'm really not
quite sure what's involved with this.
So there's a huge opportunity there for public education
so that people are better informed.
Where they did express benefits and concerns, the benefits, in general,
outweighed the concerns.
So they tended to see more positives than they could see negatives.
And by far, the biggest positive is this ability for immobile people
to be able to be freed up to go where they want to go.
The biggest concern that people have, interestingly, is around job losses.
So they're very aware, of course, that autonomous vehicles
will no longer require drivers.
So if you're a truck driver, if you're a taxi, or an Uber driver,
if you're a courier, you won't have a job in the longer term
once all vehicles are automated.
So people are quite aware that that's going to be an outcome.
And again, that brings us back to our governments
being very proactive in this space and seeing that this is coming,
and making sure that we have kind of retraining or other opportunities
available for people.
And overall, internationally, the big studies
have shown that the net employment outcome is going to be positive.
We're going to have more jobs rather than fewer,
but they're going to be based in IT.
Connected autonomous vehicles are coming.
There's no doubt about it.
We're going to have them here.
And it's a really, really good thing.
They're going to have amazing effects in terms of almost completely
eradicating traffic accidents, in terms of allowing people who otherwise can't
be mobile to be independent and get where they need to go,
in terms of reducing the number of emissions,
so that we've actually got a much healthier city to live in, and also
in terms of flexibility, allowing us to use our travel time for leisure
or for additional work to increase our productivity.
They're going to be a real boon.
They're going to change the way our cities are laid out.
They're going to change the way that our homes look.
Will they have a garage?
Or will they not, if we're using group vehicles?
The ability of those vehicles to talk to each other
will increase the efficiency of our road systems and reduce congestion.
So it's a good thing.